ceremonies were held in hiroshima japan
today to mark the 75th anniversary of
the world's first atomic bomb attack
a few days later the u.s dropped a
second nuclear bomb on nagasaki forcing
the japanese to surrender
and ending world war ii well each year
there are fewer and fewer survivors left
ramien asensio met with one of those
survivors who has spent three quarters
of a century on a quest
to rid the world of nuclear weapons
the mushroom cloud rose menacingly over
hiroshima
75 years ago today an event seared into
world history
and more so in the mind of toshiko
tanaka she was right under that cloud
just six years old and miraculously
survived
i remember the horror of that day
blinding light like
thousands of strobe lights my body
thrown to the ground
at 81 she says she's been blessed to
live
her mission now banning all nuclear
weapons
75 years after surviving the bombing i'm
all the more determined to help
rid the world of nuclear arms what
became hiroshima's ground
zero was once its humming commercial
district of nakajima
with city hall restaurants and cafes
tanaka pictured here with her father
lived close by
but on august 6 1945 the enola gay
super fortress bomber dropped its
payload on the city
a five ton nuclear bomb nicknamed little
boy
the atom bomb exploded just a third of a
mile over this river killing
an estimated 80 thousand people
instantly and leveling about 90 percent
of the city but that building now known
as the atomic bomb dome
was one of the few things left standing
a testament to the tragedy of war it now
stands aligned with tributes to peace
the peace flame and peace memorial
museum newly renovated
in time for the 75th anniversary dimmed
rooms spotlight the day of the bombing
irradiated artifacts tell the stories of
those who died in an instant
torn clothes a tricycle a lunch never
eaten
photographs of burned victims hang on
the walls next to artwork by survivors
through her own artwork tonica still
processes that fateful day
75 years ago the united states
bombed your city do you have any
criticism for america
we were full of rage at first but once
we saw the americans it was clear they
were just like
us years later she even met clifton
truman daniel grandson of president
harry truman who ordered the bombing
there will be a time in the future when
there are
no more surviving hiroshima victims what
do you want the world to remember
eliminating nuclear weapons is the path
to peace
ensuring this tragedy is never repeated
and tonica manages one
last line in english please make many
friends from
other countries when you do so you are
moving the world towards peace
a remarkable woman who survived a
nuclear bombing
yet still has peace in her heart for
cbs this morning raymie in ascencio
hiroshima japan
75 years ago and she's still pushing
right yeah i mean even just to think of
the history there and the people that
did survive when 80
000 plus were killed just like that
great to have remy there